keep your friends close and your enemies
closer
wise words but what if two of the
world's most powerful nations burned
their friendship and each other to the
ground
what if china invaded russia
what would turn china against its
strongest ally
how would the world respond
and what would happen if this conflict
went nuclear
this is what if and here's what would
happen if china invaded russia
the current relationship between china
and russia is the strongest it's been
since the 1950s and these two nations
share more than just a border
china buys most of its oil from its
neighbor to the north
in early 2022 both countries announced
collaborations on space climate change
the internet and artificial intelligence
after russia invaded ukraine and most of
the world turned against russia
china took a neutral stance
and when china set its sights on
reclaiming taiwan
russia supported china's ambitions
it's safe to say these two allies have
each other's backs
well for now
with russia's resources drained due to
its war in ukraine
china might have an opportunity to make
a massive land grab
so if this friendship between two
dictators turns deadly how would the
united states react
if china broke off its loyalty to russia
the chinese would have the edge in the
numbers department
china invests
252 billion dollars in its military
every year
that's four times what russia spends
and with most of russia's forces amassed
along european borders china could move
its massive ground forces in from the
east in a quest to control its former
allies resources and oil reserves and to
reclaim lands russia annexed in 1860
with over 2 million troops china could
dominate in a ground war
china also has 35 million soldiers in
reserve that it could call into action
at any time that show of force might
seem overwhelming but it wouldn't
compare to the russian military's
experience
right
well maybe not
during the illegal invasion of ukraine
many russian soldiers abandoned their
vehicles after running out of gas
yeah one of the world's largest oil
suppliers failed to supply its army with
enough gas
the russian army has been slow to adopt
new technology since the cold war and
fighting two wars at once
could weaken the russian soldiers
already low morale
but china may not fare much better
despite having the largest modernized
army on earth it hasn't fought a war
since 1979.
as china moved in it would find russia's
terrain hard to conquer
advancing troops across this massive
country could be brutal for both sides
russia's oil reserves could help it turn
the tide as could its fleet of armored
vehicles
russia has a tank force of 12 000 units
while china has less than 6 000 however
with the baikal mountains acting as a
natural barrier
eastern russian cities like vladivostok
could fall first to the invading army
going deeper into central russia where
the oil fields lie could be catastrophic
china could lose significant numbers of
people and equipment
while their naval forces are equal
russia's ships would be too spread out
across the seas to repel china's attack
by attacking on mass china's vast
submarine fleet could decimate russia's
pacific fleet
and would anyone come to russia's
defense
these two warring nations are the
biggest trade and political rivals of
the united states
if china and russia were at war
the u.s might just sit this one out and
let its competitors eat each other alive
let them fight
since the north atlantic treaty
organization nato was formed to respond
to the now defunct ussr
none of its 30 countries would dare to
get involved on anyone's behalf
russia might seek help from former
soviet states and trade partners like
belarus kazakhstan and cuba
but china
well that's a different story
north korea might be the only friend
they have in this fight
this conflict would be drawn out bloody
and have no end in sight
with such a desperate fight on its hands
russia would have only one card left to
play
russia has over 6 000 nuclear weapons in
its arsenal ready to strike
with only 350 known warheads china would
be outgunned
but it would only take a few strategic
hits from both sides to create a nuclear
wasteland in all of eurasia
this promise of mutually assured
self-destruction
might be the only thing that could
prevent this apocalypse
as russia continues its reign of terror
in ukraine many countries are already
seeking different oil suppliers so they
can cut off support to this regime
a china-russia war would devastate
russia's remaining trading partners and
china
if china turned on its ally no country
could ever trust them again
but
what if in the haze of war
china killed russia's supreme dictator
vladimir putin well keep watching
because that's a story
for another
what if